momentos antes del desastre
ciudadanos captaron en cámara los
últimos instantes del atr72 que perdía
el control cerca de una zona Residencial
instantes después una potente explosión
este testigo estaba presente cerca del
lugar de la peor tragedia aérea de nepal
en los últimos 30 años
cuando el avión hizo un fuerte ruido nos
volvimos y vimos caer un árbol de bambú
le dije a mi amigo que el avión estaba
cayendo al suelo y oímos el sonido de
una explosión este incidente ocurrió
entre las 10:55 y las 10:57 Llame al
número de teléfono de los servicios de
emergencia de la policía exactamente a
las 11 de la mañana nadie había llegado
aquí todavía llevamos agua en cubos y la
vertimos desde la carretera más tarde
vino la policía y rescatamos a tres
heridos con su ayuda el avión de la
compañía Airlines procedía de la capital
katmondú debía aterrizar en el
aeropuerto local de la ciudad turística
de pocora en el centro del país en el
viajaban 72 personas entre ellas seis
niños y cuatro miembros de la
tripulación las autoridades confirmaron
la muerte de 68 de ellos y debido a la
oscuridad se suspendieron las labores de
búsqueda de los cuatro restantes
serán retomadas con muy pocas esperanzas
el lunes el de este domingo es el
accidente más grave desde 1992 cuando
una aeronave de Pakistán International
Airlines cayó cerca de la capital
dejando casi 170 muertos el sector del
transporte aéreo de este país ha
experimentado un auge en los últimos
años pero la falta de formación del
personal y el mantenimiento deficiente
de las naves hacen que el peligro sea
una constante en nepal el país carece de
la infraestructura necesaria para
ofrecer previsiones meteorológicas
precisas sobre todo en las zonas remotas
y de difícil acceso la la Unión Europea
prohibió a las aerolíneas nepalíes de su
espacio aéreo por motivos de seguridad
desde 2013